let's talk about your story man how did
you get involved in all this where do
you come from
well yep i'll take you back to the
beginning because i i respect you a lot
and i told you that i think what you've
done man is is really and all the people
who have done what you've done creating
these conversations is an unquantifiable
contribution to society um
you know my story all started i'd say
came onto the public scene as a
basketball player at iowa state
university
i
you know i was an all-american high
school athlete i came up through the
nike prep circuit as well
i went to the university of minnesota
which is in my hometown
but but i i transferred to iowa state i
had to sit a year back then you got you
got penalized a year for transferring
now they they have a sort of no penalty
rule but back then you got penalized a
year so i had a city year i didn't plan
to my junior year
i had a good season and during this
season
i talked publicly about my struggles
with anxiety
and this was unique because
a lot of people in the public square
especially collegiate athletes but
really any public figures weren't
talking about mental health
as much it certainly wasn't the
mainstream sort of
buzz topic that has become now and many
could you could argue that i was sort of
the first stone in that avalanche uh and
and i'm and i'm actually kind of
disturbed and disappointed at how it
turned out and we'll talk about that
trajectory here a little bit but but
anyway um i started to talk about mental
health and i was playing well
and so it got a lot of traction because
the college sports writers were going we
never had a guy talk about anxiety but
we knew people had these issues but also
this guy is
leading his team in every major
statistical category
points rebounds blocks steals assists
and i was the only player in the country
to do that and not many players in the
country do that in any season it's kind
of a statistical anomaly
so there's this whole paradigm is
created now about
okay so what do we mean when we say
mental health then or mental health
issues or struggles or mental illness or
anxiety and so as the season went on i
continued to prove that i could compete
at the highest level
against guys who were projected to be
first round picks this went into the
ncaa tournament that's going on now my
team iowa state's playing tonight
actually um in the sweet 16 but but in
our tournament we played the defending
champs uconn coached by jim calhoun at
the time and i had an incredible game
against them they had two high-level
first-round picks projected in that game
and then we played kentucky who had
anthony davis on the team at the time
and six other first-round draft picks
projected and i and i was the dominant
player in that game so then you know the
talk was okay this guy is probably one
of the most nba ready players in his
class
i declare for the draft and something
very very
strange you could say happened
it exploded the mental health
conversation because now the question
was
how does the nba view mental illness do
they view it as a character flaw
or do they view it as
you know this
this integral piece of this
comprehensive health model right this
progressive view of health and mental
health as a spectrum where everybody has
a mental health right so that question
was posed by the the mainstream
establishment
and the answer was they did view it as a
character flaw and i push back on that
narrative immediately like as soon as
the story starts to drop sports
illustrated usa today royce is declaring
for the draft but he's a mystery pick
because of this whole anxiety
snafu um i'm going no no this ain't a
character flaw and the fact that it's
even a question proves that you guys
don't understand the real dynamic of
what's happening with this mental health
crisis
long story short i get drafted
to the houston rockets 16th but i was
projected to have a top five talent nba
ready skill set
and
upon my arrival in the nba
i discovered by reading through my
collective bargaining agreement
our cba
that there wasn't a single mention of
mental health in the entire document
and i went to my team and i said listen
i want i want to be as good of a player
and as productive as i possibly can be
for you guys but i understand that
obviously by the language in this
document that the understanding around
mental health and the issue like the one
i deal with anxiety disorders is lacking
and i'm willing to have an open
conversation with you guys transparently
about what i deal with so that we could
have a better relationship and trying to
make me the most productive player i
could be
okay they said okay that's that's good
um
okay well let's put it in writing i said
let's figure this out how does this look
in writing oh we can't put any of this
in writing i go why not the the color of
the socks a guy has to wear in the game
is in writing is it really yeah oh it
absolutely is and the penalties and the
real reason that i said we needed to put
it in writing because the cba already
had
a banned substance list that had
anti-anxiety medication on it whoa
okay so now i'm going
everybody's telling this narrative that
the pro sports world is uninitiated with
mental health as a topic but here's this
banned substance list
with
tons of
mental health related content in it so
somebody knew something about mental
health or know something and so i said
okay so let's say
for example
um
they basically said well look you can
take the xanax cause xanax was on the
banned substance you can take it don't
worry you got a doctor's prescription
and i go well wait a minute
why is it on the list
is it because if you take xanax for two
weeks
even as prescribed you can get addicted
and that is the truth about xanax it's
the most addictive drug there is in the
world
and so they were right to have it on the
banned substance list but my point was
to say hey the reason i mostly take
xanax is because
i have i have a fear of flying or that
fear the flying exacerbates my anxiety
so how about we cut some of the xanax
out per year by allowing me to drive
from minnesota to say chicago
six-hour drive a little bit longer hike
than a private charter jet you know
catered and all of that but i was
willing to take the hit because i
understood the dangers of taking xanax
for nine months continuously and they
said oh no we can't do that
and so that's where the fight began
ultimately between me and the league and
and and and i became this spokesperson
on mental health and what i was really
trying to say is like
it wasn't about me getting special
preferential treatment it was to say
that the nba
represents a global corporate community
which they do in fact
it's the watering hole for
every industry in in our society and
that there was something wrong with the
global corporate community and how they
viewed humanity and that mental health
wasn't about the dsm or diagnosis it was
to say that
mental health is another way to say the
human condition where mind body and
spirit converge and they wanted nothing
to do with that and they blackballed me
for that and they told me you're too
smart for your own good we agree with
you about mental health we agree it's an
epidemic we agree it's the crisis over
the hill but who are you to tell us to
change anything you don't have any
leverage uh so so you can either play
or you'll never become the spokesperson
that you could and we could make you be
on this issue and i've been fighting
that battle for the last 10 years did
you leave the league right away
um i gave them the ultimatum that we
needed to put a mental health policy in
place or that i wouldn't i wouldn't play
and then what happened
uh i was traded from houston to well
what happened was the houston rockets
owner at the time leslie alexander who
now sold the team to
fertitta um uh who owns it now but but
at the time
leslie alexander and his attorney
uh said to me hey
my daughter has anxiety
his name is mr goldberg he comes into
the meeting first of all they forced me
to go psychiatrists every day
and the psychiatrist told him don't do
that this isn't about him
needing psychiatric help he's telling
you guys that we need something in
writing that acknowledges mental health
as a core component of overall health
and i agree with him so then they got
pissed off at the psychiatrist
and so and and so they made me do that
every day or else i would be fined they
said so i went i said okay i'll go me
and this guy could chat it up actually
we'll start designing the policy which
we did
um and uh
basically they walked in there and after
two months of back and forth and them
telling me that you know for me to bust
to a game could be a salary cap
infringement and you know all of these
other weird kind of you know business
tactics intimidation tactics um they
finally just came in and said they had a
they sent an emissary right and it was
this attorney and he goes listen my
daughter has anxiety she doesn't like to
fly either but i make her and she'll
thank me for it later she hates me now
um i agree with you this is a big issue
and if you agree to go to our d-league
which is now called the g-league minor
league affiliate
um in the off-season i'll help you put
this mental policy in place and i'll
make sure that the owners accept it when
the off-season came there was no talk of
that policy and i was traded to
philadelphia
um and philadelphia released me before
the season started even though the local
media there in philly thought that i was
a shoe-in to make that team
but sam hinkey who was who had been the
assistant gm under daryl mori who's an
interesting character in this whole uh
story arc um he was the understudy of
daryl mori so they basically did a trade
and dump
um and and i was you know 21 years old i
was naive i had the inclination or the
instinct to block the trade
but i was encouraged by the union that
it would be maybe advantageous for me
because philadelphia is in this east
coast coast corridor and there's a lot
of games that i would be able to drive
to
uh throughout the season so you know
ultimately after the philadelphia thing
i just didn't get another shot i wrote
letters i you know i i had had medical
professionals mental health
professionals write letters and say this
mental health issue is real that the nba
is in a perfect position to
to
back up it's it's
it's promotion of caring about the
greater good um by by just putting in a
very simple doable mental health policy
and they just ignored me why do you
think they did that
at the time i thought it was because
they didn't there was something they
didn't know
i was arrogant i was mistaken i was
naive i thought that i was going to be
able to bridge the gap through genuine
participation
of some type of some type of
attitude or perspective that they had
gotten wrong
but that wasn't the case
the entire corporatocracy knew that
psychological
uh that the the predatory
uh predation let's say on on the human
psychology was the next iteration of the
war that they wanted to wage on the
common people i didn't i didn't get that
at the time that social media was around
the corner and the dopamine
uh the the dopamine war was coming down
the her coming around the they knew it
so when i went to talk about mental
health and say hey hold on there's a
mental health there's a cultural mental
health
renaissance and revolution that needs to
happen here right now
i'm sitting there thinking that they had
archaic views about mental health but i
was mistaken they were advanced around
the human psychology and they plan to be
predatory with it so they were planning
on like like they knew that it was going
to be weaponized like like mental
illness would be weaponized so they
didn't want to get involved in it or
something let me introduce real quick
there are companies when it comes to
mobile apps there was a viral i covered
this several years ago a company says we
can program your audience for you so
when you've got big companies that are
planning on making mobile apps they're
going to consultants saying how can we
make it so that people become addicted
to this
and then the company will analyze their
data and be like do these things and
people will become addicts yeah it's
digital addictions so um and you can you
can
uh
place that or stand that next to a 21
year old kid coming in saying hey why is
the alcohol cut off not at halftime
why is it okay why is it morally and
ethically okay for us to use taxpayer
money to build these arenas and then
build parking structures where we
basically incentivize people to drink
and drive with their kid or come to the
game and get drunk in front of their kid
or or even worse somebody else's kid and
yell this belligerent [ __ ] at the game
like
they were like and i'm sitting here
saying all this based on logic and
reason they're like we're about to go to
town on the working class through
psychological
manipulation
i think i think it it's it's it's
simpler put to be honest because i think
you know the way you describe it is
is what's happening but the attitude is
probably like how much did we just pay
this guy to make our mobile app that
that makes these these young kids
addicted to it 50 million 50 million we
can't have this guy screwing that up
yeah
right so they thought you were a threat
to the system that you're going to gain
too much power and influence in the
system twofold twofold
yes
but there's there's a canary in a coal
mine in this situation yes
in the immediate they're like uh this
kid is trying to change the status quo
and that's a danger but the mental
health topic as a topic in general
is the one topic that puts a mirror up
to the individual
so in spirit they didn't want to have
the mental health conversation because
they didn't want to have to look at
themselves
your story to me sounds like you know
you you thought that once you got in
people would be willing to engage with
you and you'd have a positive impact but
the reality is for for any for political
office even you end up getting into a
position where there's a train coming at
you and you're trying to push against it
that train is going to keep coming
so you go in and good faith think you're
gonna have this impact and then we hear
it across the board from the presidency
to members of congress so like as soon
as you get in the machine controls you
yeah that and then if you if you resist
it enough eventually the machine just
shoves you out of the way
and you know
as a young kid growing up i grew up in
the michael jordan era
right in the twin cities i mean chicago
wgn we got all the local bulls games
we had wgn in twin cities so we got to
see all the homebulls games so i was a
basketball lover right and when you
when you grow up in a single mother
household
and she pays the rent with her tips
and and you go to the gym and you create
a relationship with the with the local
recreation center uh manager and and he
allows you to spend that extra time in
the gym all by yourself just shooting
just shooting playing games with
yourself to a hundred i'm the bulls one
night i'm the other team the other night
you grow up with a
a a very naive view of what the
basketball industry or basketball itself
is all about
and and i really thought uh that the nba
was this
institution
that was that was based on all of the
things that basketball had been for me
growing up a safe haven a place of of
teamwork and hard work genuineness
meritocracy uh and you get there and
it's just like nah kid that we're a cog
in the machine and and don't don't rail
against us because we'll squash you how
do you get so so what's the next step in
this process for you how do you get from
there to now you're running as you're
running as a republican against omar
seems like there's a big the big
something big happened between them well
a lot of things happen but but mainly
that
the same liberal establishment that i've
watched take hold of the the cultural
narrative over the last 10 years was the
same one that tried to defame me and
poke fun at me 10 years ago it's the
same one that is uh making a lot of
money in china absolutely
and and so
you know it
i was in canada for two years i saw them
go after jordan peterson i was living
there playing for london lightning in
london ontario in the the uh the
national basketball league canada
and
i watched that
it was the most peculiar thing
because i was a nomad up until that
point was a cultural democrat as many
young black men are growing up in these
inner cities they're cultural democrats
although they tend to be conservative
really culturally but in party
affiliation they tend to be democrat
um and it's just the oddest thing to me
i'd never seen
just me personally for somehow i had
never seen people go after somebody who
was so reasonable and logical and just
seemed to be kind of a nice guy with
such obscene and ridiculous
points
and i'm sitting here as a person who
fought the nba going
i have genuine points about the
establishment that we should be talking
about why are you guys going after him
about pronouns i don't get it and so i
watched that
and then i came back from canada played
in the big three
um and while i was playing in the big
three i started to talk about you know
broader
issues politically edward snowden
um julian assange the the concentration
camps in china epstein you know all this
was back in 2019
and then i wrote a book an open letter
to lebron james entitled epistle to the
king and i basically lay this out from
post-world war ii
uh all the way up until the the 2016
election of donald trump of how the
black community has been basically used
as this lynchpin this cultural lynchpin
of this marxist you know this sort of
marxist globalist revolution
uh and then george floyd happened
and you were right there well the
pandemic happened first yeah and i was i
was introduced to steve bannon's show i
was introduced to his pbs frontline
interview i had already knew about him
since 2000 you know since trump ran but
i didn't really do a deep dive i still
had a surface view of him
then i saw the pbs line interview and
then the pandemic broke out
then i got introduced to war room like
as soon as the pandemic broke out and i
was listening to it every day it was the
most accurate
uh coverage of the pandemic at the day
was pretty much some of the only
coverage and then george floyd happened
two months later in may that was march
and then made george floyd happen what
did that change for you
go ahead i just got to bring up one
quick point as we get into george floyd
you know that story about the mural of
george floyd with the crown that got
struck by lightning exploded
i don't know that story there's a wall
there's another mural yeah and oh so you
see so in the middle was was george
floyd it was a crown over his head
on a a partly cloudy day
meteorologists reported a lightning
strike witnesses said they saw the
lightning strike and it blew out only
george floyd from the building the whole
building was like no no roof damage
that's just a freaky story that i you
know i want to bring up you know
whenever it comes to the george floyd
stuff because that's crazy
god's wrath it's fast or metallic that's
right we're both
good but like like someone staged it or
something i don't know that's crazy is
that true
this is someone's stage oh no no i have
no explanation okay yeah like god's
wrath yeah i don't know man
that's what a lot of people felt like or
that that lady who was mocking the the
pandemic and then you see this one the
comedian
and then she just faints just like falls
back and hits her head yeah she was she
was making fun of me i just wanted to
bring up the george floyd thing because
there's a
that weird moment that happened but uh
so well she said jesus loves me the most
right that's when she fell down that's
right
i was like
jesus loves everyone the same
yeah
christianity
taking god's name in vain is a is a
grave sin and and the wrath is quick you
really can't believe i i don't i'm not
worth messing around i don't want to
derail i just want to mention that story
because it's crazy but so so now george
floyd so look the george floyd thing
happened so i i write this letter to
lebron james where i basically lay out
how black people specifically pop black
figures have been used as a three-card
monty uh to to not only
keep the black community in this
subverse you know uh in this place of
submission
as a community but they've been used to
now go and attack the rights of others
on the grounds of this cultural you know
this culture war and an information war
so i lay this out in the book the book's
255 pages it ends up being it's like 40
000 words or something and then george
floyd happens and my whole point to
lebron james was to say that in the
position you've been given god given
that you have an obligation
to lead in a way that's more genuine
authentic and honest that was the whole
crooks of the book but i had to go
through the history right to because i
can't i can't just assume that he's
initiated into
this post-world war ii liberal world
order type you know i just didn't assume
that so i kind of took him through it in
good faith and then george floyd happens
and i'm like oh
i just wrote about what i need to go do
right and so
i knew from watching the narrative be be
uh you know
crafted and manipulated by the the
mainstream media that they were going to
try and hijack that moment in a variety
of ways and i knew that i was perfectly
positioned to go into
my community and lead in a way that that
changed the narrative and that's what i
did we
you know uh we led several first of all
chaos broke out there was fires there
was unrest real real unrest that was on
the verge of being anarchy it was
anarchy but it was on the verge of
getting really out there um
and in the middle of that i said i
called my basketball friends up other
guys who have big names in minnesota
sports community at least and i said we
got to go do something i'm leaving this
protest if you don't come
don't shake my hand we're not friends no
more this is you guys got to put more in
and we led peaceful protests
but i wasn't going to allow the
mainstream media or their blm subsidiary
uh dictate the tone of the protest so
instead of going to the first precinct
we went to the federal reserve
right
and and uh you know a lot of these young
white liberal women who want to
participate and and you know we're are
really passionate and active i'm sitting
on top of the stoop outside the outside
of the federal reserve and we're doing a
die in at the federal reserve and
they're looking at me like i got three
eyes like why are we here
and that's when it hit me
it hit me that
this this entire
this entire cultural war information war
is not just a byproduct of individual
people uh having low morals and ethics
that is a part of it but but the
establishment has gotten really good at
fooling people and i and i was able to
go out and fight that uh just by being
one man
with a profile in my community that had
gained the respect of a few people in my
immediate circle
uh and who would stand around me at a
moment of of chaos and turmoil and lead
physically take dominion in the
community and say hey if you have a
grievance that's great that's that's
good you should participate as a citizen
peacefully
and if you want to negotiate the social
contract between you and the state you
first have to identify the institutions
that really preside over you so we're on
our way to the fed and if you don't know
what the fed is when we get here and do
this dying i'm going to tell you a
little bit about it
the mainstream media didn't even want to
cover that they they wanted it to seem
like i was a emerging
uh civil rights activist for black lives
matter and they didn't want to give me
any air time once again to explain my
position because it's antithetical to
what they were trying to accomplish and
so that's how eventually
um in 2020 when we played with the big
three again
jeff kwadnitz who was a co-owner with
ice cube used to be partners with steve
bannon and i told jeff if you don't
introduce me to steve
me and you aren't friends anymore
and jeff goes i got you he sends me the
number right away and i get hooked up
with steve we start to have great
conversations build a relationship he's
a mentor friend of mine and and the rest
is history thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there